لنعرف تفاصيل المشهد في ديار بكر وطبعا
واضحه الدمار خلفك سلام صفيرينا ماذا يجري
هناك
عبد الصمد احدى المدن المتضرره هي مدينه
ديار بكر كما ذكرت السلطات المحليه تقول
ان سبعه مباني انهارت بشكل كلي في هذه
المدينه عدد الضحايا حتى الان وصل الى 300
قتيل هذا احد المباني الذي تضررت انهارت
بشكل كامل حقيقه طواقم الانقاذ لا تزال
تعمل يشتبهون بوجود تقريبا 30 شخص تحت
الانقاض ولكن
يعني الغالبيه المبنى تم انتهاء العمل
عليه والان يتم رفع الانقاذ فقط في احد
جوانب المبنى يتم البحث عن امكانيه العثور
على اشخاص تحت الانقاض لن يتم الحديث عن
وضع هؤلاء الاشخاص لكن يقدرون ان نحو 30
شخصا لا يزالون تحت الانقاض لا نعرف وضع
هؤلاء الاشخاص فرق الانقاذ تطلب ان تكمل
عملها قبل الاعلان عن وضعيه هؤلاء الاشخاص
المشكله الكبرى في ديار بكر عبد الصمد
رغم ان عدد المباني التي انهارت بشكل كلي
قليلا نسبيا مقارنه بمدن اخرى ولكن الضرر
الاكبر هو على المباني التي لم لم تنهار
بشكل جزئي او كلي بل تضررت السلطات اضطرت
الى اخلاء الف مبنى في المدينه من قاطنه
هذه المباني ايلا للسقوط في اي لحظه بعد
الكشف على اساسات هذه المباني تبين انها
غير صالحه للسكن على الاطلاق اكثر من الف
مبنى تقريبا في هذه المدينه التي يعيش
فيها قرابه مليون و800 الف شخص تقريبا
العائلات التي اجنيت من هذه المباني التي
تقترب من الالف مبنى تم انشاء نقطتين
لاسكانهم بشكل مؤقت خيم نقلوا اليها من
قبل فرق الانقاذ والسلطات المحليه بطبيعه
الحال الى حين يعني ايجاد اماكن بديله لهم
ايضا هناك بحسب ما علمنا هناك فرق مختصه
تقوم في هذه الاثناء بالكشف في احد
الاحياء القديمه في مدينه ديار بكر تقوم
بالكشف عن على وضع المباني والمنازل
الموجوده في المدينه القديمه في ديار بكر
قد تكون ايضا غير صالحه لبقاء السكان هناك
وبالتالي قد نكون امام عمليه اجراء اخرى
من الحي القديم في مدينه ديار بكر
طبعا الوضع هنا كما في كل المدن المنكوبه
الوضع متوتر العائلات تنتظر ولكن
الشرطه المحليه في ديار بكر وايضا عناصر
الجيش قاموا بوضع حواجز تمنع العائلات من
الاقتراب من اماكن الدمار الطرق متضرره
حيث نقف نحن هناك واحد من الطرق ايضا تم
اقفاله بشكل كامل لان احدى يعني بعض اجزاء
هذا الطريق قد تضرر بشكل كبير وهناك خشيه
ايضا من انهياره
بموازاه عمليه البحث والانتشار والانقاذ
هناك عمليات اغاثه تتم على نطاق واسع في
ديار بكر سواء من المتطوعين المحليين او
ايضا فرق متطوعه اتت من خارج مدينه ديار
بكر شكرا لك سلام خضر مراسلات الجزيره
ميديا بكر كما اشكر ايضا فرح الزمن شوقي
كانت معنا من انقره من داخل اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ وشكرا لمنتصر ابو نبوت مراسل
الجزيره من غازي ع